und jetzt das heute journal mit gundula
gause und claus kleber
guten abend wenn wir in den nachrichten
jetzt permanent von kopf an kopf rennen
sprechen dann ist das für news leute und
zuschauer irgendwann mal kalter kaffee
aber nicht für die beteiligten für die
heißt kopf an kopf das in den letzten
stunden des letzten endspurts vielleicht
noch was zu holen sein könnte und
niemand will morgen nacht mit dem
gedanken ins bett gehen das am samstag
doch noch was zu holen gewesen wäre und
außerdem wie sähe das denn aus
nachlassen heute also war nach schluss
kundgebungen gestern nach lauf heute
karl hinterleitner packt das
bemerkenswerteste zusammen
die größte bühne heute hatte armin
laschet auftritt mit der kanzlerin in
aachen nicht immer waren sich in der
vergangenheit alle ganz sicher ob
merkels unterstützung für laschet
wirklich von herzen kommt heute nimmt
der kandidat ihre anwesenheit als gutes
omen
2017 vor vier jahren vier monaten und 13
tagen waren wir auch hier auf diesem
platz einen tag vor der landtagswahl
alle haben gesagt ob das gut geht damals
war angela merkel genau hier und ich bin
sicher weil sie heute wieder es wird es
auch morgen gelingen die cdu als
stärkste politische kraft
[Applaus]
der direkte konkurrent ums kanzleramt
gut gelaunt olaf scholz zeitgleich in
potsdam sein wahlkampfteam besser laufen
können deutliche gewinne in diesem jahr
und im sommer überholte die spd die
union in seiner rede heute stellt olaf
scholz soziale themen in den mittelpunkt
kinderarmut wohnungsnot und den
mindestlohn
ich habe mich immer dafür eingesetzt
dass deutschland einen mindestlohn
bekommt weil ich einfach zu viele kennen
und kennen gelernt haben zu wenig
verdienen und ich möchte das hier jetzt
noch mal einen großen schritt machen zu
sorgen dass dem investor den wir heute
in deutschland haben nach oben gesetzt
wird dass er auf zwölf euro angehoben
wird nur einen steinwurf entfernt scholz
direkte wahlkreis konkurrentin in
potsdam annalena baerbock bundesweit
führte die grünen-chefin das trio in den
umfragen einmal an jetzt werden sie und
ihre partei wohl aller voraussicht
darauf platz drei landen weerberg heute
noch einmal mit den grünen kernthemen
wir haben in der pandemie aber auch in
dem wahlkampf überall gespielt dass
menschen sagen wir können das doch mit
dem klimaschutz vor ort wir können
bessere kitas und schulen schaffen im
gesundheitsbereich sind pflegerinnen und
pfleger über sich hinausgewachsen und
dieser wunsch nach einer erneuerung
darum geht es jetzt am sonntag das zu
wählen und mit voller kraft eine neue
bundesregierung einzubringen es war die
letzte show down der drei kandidierenden
im wahlkampf der damit jetzt endgültig
vorbei ist in weniger als 24 stunden ist
klar wer beim regent ums kanzleramt als
erster ins ziel kommt
wir werden sehen man frau hat sich ja
daran gewöhnt dass sofort nach
schließung der wahllokale 18 uhr 1 schon
ziemlich klar ist wie das ergebnis wird
auch wenn diese prognosen wesentlich auf
befragungen von wählern beruht die
gerade aus dem wahllokal kamen die
demoskopen haben erfahrungsgemäß ganz
gut raus wie diese angaben gewichtet und
getunt werden müssen normalerweise theo
morgen ist dann aber wohl doch nicht
alles so normal
das kann man glaube ich wirklich hier
mit fug und recht sagen und nicht nur
weil der anteil der briefwähler so hoch
ist wie nie und die auszählung schlicht
länger dauern fraktion vor allem weil
bei der union morgen kanzleranspruch und
kapitale krise ganz nah beieinander
liegen werden sollte die union anders
als in umfragen vorne liegen oder auf
augenhöhe mit der spd sein dann wird
armin laschet die regierungsbildung
beanspruchen was aber wenn die union auf
platz zwei landet wie groß darf dann der
abstand zur spd seien um dennoch zu
sondieren und bei welchem abstand wird
die innerparteiliche kritik an asche so
laut werden dass es seine gesamte
position infrage stellt die csu
jedenfalls hat die latte für ihn schon
sehr hoch gelegt nur wer vorne ist darf
ans kanzleramt klopfen es spielt den
ball gleich nach münchen dort ist stefan
leifert der chef unseres großen
landesstudios dort die csu stefan hat
sich ja ziemlich zusammen genommen
nachdem ihr markus söder armin laschet
unterlegen war und nicht kanzlerkandidat
werden durfte was wird jetzt in münchen
los sein wenn der abend wenn er armin
laschet morgen abend nicht liefern kann
und als zweiter durchs ziel geht
ja dann würden hier bei der csu die
messe rausgeholt werden die in den
letzten wochen so gründlich geschärft
worden sind das minimalziel hat die csu
ausgegeben für die union die union muss
auf platz eins landen das war die klare
ansage hier von csu-chef söder sollte
dieses minimalziel nicht erreicht werden
dann würde der unmut sich bahn brechen
der sich über kandidat und kampagne der
cdu in den letzten wochen angestaut hat
das ziel bei einem schlechten
abschneiden der union aus csu sicht wäre
auf jeden fall das von der schuld und
verantwortung möglichst wenig bei ihr
hängen bleibt und möglichst viel
abgeladen werden kann bei der cdu und
ihrem kandidaten und das würde es für
armin laschet dann schwierig machen als
zweitplatzierter sondierungsgespräche
zum beispiel für eine jamaika koalition
zu führen hintergrund dessen ist dass
die csu hier in bayern in zwei jahren
landtagswahlen zu bestreiten hat und das
ist aus csu sicht viel wichtiger als
bundestagswahlen wie sie morgen
stattfinden also so oder so sollte die
union wirklich auf platz zwei landen
kommen auf cdu und csu ziemlich
turbulente tage zu wie schafe denn da
gelesen in münchen wenn es dann 0,1
prozent oder so was hinter der spd liegt
werden dann die gleichen langen messer
gezückt
da wird im moment gerechnet klar ist je
kleiner der abstand ist zwischen spd auf
platz 1 und union auf platz zwei wenn es
denn so kenne desto schwerer wird es für
die csu natürlich dagegen zu opponieren
zb für eine jamaika-koalition gespräche
zu führen aber wenn dazwischen sagen wir
mal mehr als zwei prozent liegen dann
bitte in der csu hier der aufstand
losbrechen na dann geben wir nicht noch
tiefer ins spekulations land theo
wählerinnen und wähler treffen ja was
den kanzler angeht tatsächlich nur die
vorentscheidung morgen wer es dann wird
vereinbaren koalitionen ist schon
irgendwie abzusehen wie das anlaufen
wird vielleicht schon morgen nacht ja
also soweit ich weiß hat es auch schon
erste kontakte gegeben ab morgen greift
dann ein arzt dreistufiges verfahren es
beginnt mit bilateralen chefgesprächen
sicher schon in den nächsten tagen dann
folgen genauere inhaltliche sondierungen
und möglicherweise gleichzeitig für
unterschiedliche koalitionsmodelle und
erst dann würden formelle
koalitionsverhandlungen von alle wollen
in die wiederholung von 2017 vermeiden
als es ja fast ein halbes jahr gedauert
hat aber noch nie gab es so viele
koalitionsmöglichkeiten wie bei dieser
wahl so schätzen wir wir wissen nicht
dankeschön theo und stefan hier geht es
weiter mit nachrichten von 100 auf fast
zweieinhalb millionen wahlberechtigte in
berlin wählen morgen auch ein neues
abgeordnetenhaus und zwölf
bezirksparlamente
außerdem können sie bei einem
volksentscheid darüber abstimmen ob
große wohnungskonzern enteignet werden
sollen für die spd war spitzenkandidatin
gefallen noch einmal umstimmen ebenso
wie die kandidatin der grünen jahre die
linke will das rot rot grüne bündnis im
abgeordnetenhaus fortsetzen dagegen
kämpft die cdu ebenso wie fdp und auch
die afd alle umwarben noch einmal
unentschlossene wähler
und auch in mecklenburg vorpommern wird
parallel zur bundestagswahl ein neuer
landtag gewählt
laut umfragen liegt die spd mit
ministerpräsidentin schwesig erneut
fahren der cdu-spitzenkandidat sack
drohen weitere verluste zudem trotzdem
setzt sie auf fortsetzung der großen
koalition in schwerin
die afg kann mit einem wiedereinzug in
den landtag rechnen ebenso wie die linke
grüne und fdp hoffen auf den
wiedereinzug ins landesparlament
die mitnahme von masken in fahrzeugen
soll pflicht werden ab kommendem jahr
gehören demnach zwei mund nase
bedeckungen in die verbands gäste von
autos lkw und bussen sonst droht ein
bußgeld so pläne des
bundesverkehrsministeriums die aktuellen
corona zahlen die bundesweite sieben
tage incidents ist wieder gesunken laut
robert-koch-institut auf 60,6
zinsen heute abend hier darf eine schwer
geprüfte einfache chinesische bürger
wenn nach drei harten jahren in
vancouver kanada endlich wieder
heimischen boden betreten so beschreibt
es frau mängel in der ferne habe sie die
wärme und sorge der chinesischen nation
und des volkes gespürt
vielleicht hat es den schmerz der frau
mengen auch gelindert dass sie ihre
quasi untersuchungshaft in einer ihrer
eigenen millionen dollar willen in
vancouver verbringen durfte inklusive
freigang verein kauf strips während us
und kanadischen behörden nachzuweisen
versuchten das frau mengen illegale
geschäfte mit iran gemacht hatte frau
mengen das musste man bislang ist bei
huawei den großen hightech konzerns
ihres vaters finanzchef in china hat für
diese person noch mehr gesorgt als nur
mit anwaltlichen beistand es fanden sich
kanadier in china die festgenommen
werden und gegen frauen frei getauscht
werden konnten die beiden kanadier haben
ein völlig anderes schicksal hinter sich
johannes hano berichtet in roten kostüm
auf rotem teppich wie eine film-diva
stegmann finanzchefin des chinesischen
technologieriesen highway nach ihrer
landung in jenson aus dem flugzeug die
ankunft eine schwülstige inszenierung
mehr als 1000 tagen leiden bin ich
endlich wieder in der heimat das lange
warten in einem fremden land war folter
meine füße wieder auf dem warmen boden
des heimatlandes zu haben erregt mich
mehr sich jetzt beschreiben kann
mutterland ich bin zurück
eine ganz andere eine leise ankunft
heute nacht im kanadischen calgary nach
knapp drei jahren einzelhaft in china
waren die beiden michaels wie sie in
kanada genannt werden zurück in der
freiheit begrüßt von kanadas
premierminister justin krueger michael
kovak ex diplomat und
menschenrechtsaktivist und der
geschäftsmann michael spamer wurden
opfer im großen spiel der mächte im
dezember 2018 wurden sie in china unter
fadenscheinigen vorwürfen wegen
angeblicher spionage verhaftet ganz
kanada heute erleichtert
diese beiden männer sind durch
unvorstellbare qualen
1000 tage lang haben sie stärke
durchhaltevermögen und widerstandskraft
gezeigt
sie haben uns alle inspiriert
comic on spey waren 2018 in china
verhaftet worden kurz nachdem kanadische
behörden machen so auf bitten der usa
wegen bank betrug und dem verstoß gegen
das iran embargo festgenommen hatten
unter lockerem hausarrest in ihrer 4
millionen dollar villa in vancouver
wehrte sie sich gegen die auslieferung
als die us behörden das verfahren
gestern unter auflagen aus setzten
werden die beiden michaels aus ihrer
einzelhaft in china entlassen und
mourinho sitzt im flieger nach münchen
dort wusste sie bei ihrer ankunft bei
wem sie sich dafür bedanken musste
residenz die thinking kümmern sich um
sicherheit und wohlbefinden eines jeden
einzelnen chinesischen bürgers und er
hat sich auch um mich gekümmert das hat
mich tief berührt auch
wenn chinas kommunisten einen
zusammenhang bestreiten der fall macht
klar alle die in china geschäfte machen
oder sich dort engagieren müssen ab
jetzt damit rechnen zur
verhandlungsmasse zu werden wenn es
chinas führung passt
das ist das live bild des kanadischen
fernsehens vom ausbruch des vulkans auf
palma der kleinsten kanarischen insel
gewaltig brodelnde lava aus immer wieder
neu aufbrechenden spalten
unbeirrbare kraft der natur der menschen
absolut gar nichts entgegenzusetzen
haben menschen können nur hilflos
zuschauen und wenn es soweit ist der
katastrophe davonlaufen ein ende ist
nicht abzusehen thomas walde mit bildern
von heute und aus den letzten tagen am
flughafen von la palma landete am mittag
nur die asche der flugbetrieb ist
weitgehend eingestellt und darum sitzen
viele touristen im wörtlichen sinne auf
gepackten koffern am hafen von la palma
versuchen sie von der insel zu kommen
vielen bleibt nur dieses verkehrsmittel
da sind wir feinde tatsachen gestellt
worden dass leider der flug ausfällt
jetzt versuchen wir mit dem schiff nach
dem river zu fahren und haben dann auf
unsere eigenen kosten ein flug gebucht
von teneriffa nach
zuvor hatten die behörden die
evakuierung weiterer auto angeordnet
denn der combo wie ich ja hatte sich
nach einer woche der eruptionen nicht
beruhigt immer wieder überrascht er die
experten
eine neue eruption hat sich gerade
ereignet und wir müssen schnell hier weg
weil sich gerade ein neuer riss an der
flanke des kegels geöffnet hat
experten sagen die akute phase des
vulkans sei hochexplosiv dabei sind auch
anwohner die bislang nicht gezwungen
waren zu gehen bereits erschöpft die
fixe tasche weg um sich abzulenken weil
du nicht den ganzen tag damit verbringen
kannst dieses monster anzusehen wie es
deine leute und deine insel auffrisst
ich fühle hilflosigkeit weil wir es so
aus der nähe siehst aber dann in
bekannten nicht helfen kannst sie sind
wie familie
die explosionen der ascheregen und der
lärm zermürben die anwohner weiter und
ein ende ist bislang nicht absehbar
es fehlt noch der samstag service
wetteraussichten und lottozahlen sie
lauten ohne gewähr 19 20
27 30 41 47 superzahl 7 mehr auf lotto
zdf de und im zdf text auf seite 55 6
das wetter wird ab morgen erst einmal
unbeständig und regnerisch
einige teils kräftige schauer und
gewitter gibt es morgen schon im
südwesten sonst ist es nach auflösung
der nebelfelder bewölkt aber es bleibt
trocken bei 19 bis 26 grad die neue
woche beginnt wechselhaft mit schauern
und gewittern am montag werden noch 19
bis 24 grad erreicht bis mittwoch kühlt
es auf 14 bis 20 grad ab allerdings
können sie uns glauben wir sind gespannt
auf morgen und rein uns ein in eine
lückenlose folge von
informationssendungen morgen es beginnt
um 17 uhr und geht bis mitternacht 21.45
darin dass schon da bis dann und alles
vom sport jetzt gleich im sportstudio
bei selfoss der markt bummel mark van
bommel zu gast hat gute unterhaltung
dabei
[Musik]